if you look at the Republican position
on climate change and Donald Trump's
statements on climate change they come
closest to the national policies of
Nicaragua Syria and North Korea the
Republican Party is the only major
political party in the world that does
not seem to accept the basic science
that the world is warming and that we
are causing it that's the central
starting point of his energy and climate
instincts and we'll see how real that
belief really is I think the biggest
unknown is what Donald Trump actually
thinks we don't know if he will actually
try to shut down the EPA we don't know
if on his first day he will walk away
from the Paris climate Accords without
the Paris climate agreement in place and
the entire community of nations really
watching each other
scrutinizing each other's actions to see
how well everyone's reducing emissions
emissions may just rise as easy as it is
to speculate what I focus on is trying
to identify these unknown questions at
this point that's sort of as far as we
can go
you